- [Kelly Clarkson] So
Will Smith plays your Dad.
Was that crazy?
Like, were you nervous to meet him?
- [Both] Yeah.
(Kelly laughs)
- I love that every
answer will be in unison.
(all laugh)
- [Demi Singleton] I know.
That's just how we naturally talk now
when we're together.
But yeah, I was definitely nervous
meeting Mr. Will.
He's the "Fresh Prince
of Bel-Air", you know.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- I grew up wa--
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly Clarkson]
Philadelphia, born and raised.
- [Both] Right?
- On the playground.
- [Both] Where you spent most of the days.
- Yeah. Crazy. It's crazy.
No, it is a crazy thing,
and he's done so many films
and he's had just such an amazing career.
I just can't imagine being so young
and then being arou--
or even my age,
being around someone
like that and being like,
"Oh my God, you've done
so many amazing things".
"You're such a great actor."
- I mean, he's pretty phenomenal.
- [Saniyya Sidney] No, yeah.
- Just like you said, despite,
he had so much success,
but despite that he's so humble.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah
he seems genuinely cool.
- And so,
kind, you know.
When you speak to him,
it's just like speaking
to any normal person.
[Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- That's what people really love.
- And he has the best shoe game.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Best shoe game?
- The best shoe game I've
ever seen in like ever.
- Shoe game as in like Nike's?
Like that kinda, like
sneakers? I love sneakers.
- I mean, it's like,
Nike's.
It's like Air Jordan Ones.
And he doesn't tie his shoes.
Like that's his thing.
[Kelly Clarkson] What?
- He doesn't tie his
shoes. He doesn't want to.
- That's just like trying
to break your ankle.
(laughing)
That's just dangerous is what that is.
I love sneakers.
That's my whole closet.
This is not what I looked
like in my off time.
(laughing)
This is not-- this is all fake news.
(audience laughing)
So how you-- gotta be honest with me,
like how we're Will Smith's tennis skills?
Like, oh.
Your eyes.
(laughing)
You were like,
so.
Wait. Don't, y'all usually have to,
for films, have to like
really go hardcore?
And like practice for what you're doing?
Oh, so y'all did. He didn't?
- So we did. We did some--
we did some very intense tennis training,
but Mr. Will did not.
And that's mostly because
Richard didn't play.
He didn't know how to play tennis.
He kind of taught himself
in order to teach Serena and Venus.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Oh.
- [Demi Singleton] He
had really no experience
with the sport until
he decided that he felt that would be best
for his girls.
So Mr. Will did not
train as much as we did.
(laughing)
- It's still respectful
'cause you're calling him Mr. Will.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
That's awesome. It's nice. It's nice.
- Yeah, it was a lot
of fun playing with him
because I feel like it made
us feel like we were so good
because you know,
(laughing)
(crowd applause)
- You can't hear that enough.